[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance in kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people are brilliant guests today I'm
delighted to say he's a comedy writer
behind some of the most beloved shows in
the history of television Graham Linehan
welcome to trigonometry thank you thank
you very much for asking it's a pleasure
to have you on
I did mention obviously in the intro
that you're you you wrote father Ted
black books the IT Crowd you were part
of the team behind a whole bunch of
other shows but more recently you've
also become very controversial and
problematic which is one of the reasons
we're extra delighted to have you but
before we get into that we had the bunch
of questions just about comedy for you
as well so it seems to me grown that and
this is someone genuinely is a massive
forehead of your work that you operate
in what could be seen as a golden age of
comedy you know the 90s the early
noughties where there was lots of money
to be made and there I say it people
were a lot braver now how do you think
the comedy landscape has changed over
those last 10 to 15 years have we become
better more progressive things got a
little bit worse would you say when you
say more progressive how do you mean do
you mean yes I mean I mean the quality
of comedy do you think that we've
improved or the content has improved or
do you think that we progressed slightly
do you think that dare I say the people
are less able to make certain jokes
because they're deemed to be not
examiner yeah well you know that's them
I mean the most revealing to think to me
that always happens is when someone like
Dave Chappelle brings out a special and
the headlines read things like Dave
Chappelle
his attack on Michael Jackson victims
you know when you know you look at the
you look in it and it's it's a setup for
a joke
it's obviously to set up for a joke so
so you have a very odd situation at the
moment where journalists who are kind of
who are kind of set themselves up as
cultural gatekeepers are pretending that
that for some reason people like Dave
Chappelle Adam and Louise CK I realize
he's more problematic but but they're
pretending that these people are serious
when they're telling jokes and they
write them down in journalism pieces
like I know em louis c.k made a routine
about those kids who were all shot and
david hog people like that who then went
on and and and you know became leaders
of an anti-gun movement he made a
routine about them something I think he
said they were something like selfish
you know such an absurd thing to say
immediately about about people who've
been the subject of gun attacks you know
at their school and yet it's reported in
this most it's reported as if he's I
don't know he's Trump or something on
your very point I wrote a piece about it
so I remember the details quite
carefully quite accurately I think he I
didn't actually joke about the people
that had been shot what he joked about
is the fact that the people who weren't
shot were then being held up in the
media as these Paragons of virtue and
truth upon the gun debate and he was
saying the fact that you pushed some fat
kid in front of you doesn't make you
more interesting which is so obviously
you know said to produce a huge laugh
from the audience you know
no serious anyway so and so there's a
kind of a weird propaganda exercise
going on where all these woke morons are
pretending the comedians are serious so
so I think I can't and also an
interesting thing happened to me during
my cancellation
I've had one or two people big names
meet me for lunch and very kindly I mean
you know they don't they don't say they
they don't say anything publicly does
rust it Jonathan Ross it's been an
absolute star but a few other people
meet me privately and talk to me about
it and one guy met me and he said he
said a comedian friend of his said the
joke that would destroy my career is
already out there and and and and that's
something that should scare all of us
because what it means is that I don't
know who said this I think it was rich
alone or someone you may know cause I'm
going for he said something like give me
three letters by a person and I shall
destroy them something like that which
means that you know you can even dig
into any correspondence and find stuff
that will hang someone so imagine you
have a comedians entire Twitter history
which which existed before all these
taboos became taboos and can be just
used to just you know used used to
destroy people and I think also another
thing that's happening are people like
Owen Jones and and and people like that
are doing a similar thing they're
finding I got something that happened to
me during all of this was them the
what's-her-name
Linda Riley of diva the lesbian magazine
for men and Lee Watson of of Geo triple
ad I think it is they both do what they
did I mean so obvious what they did they
a search on my Twitter timeline for
words like Conte and [ __ ]
you know they found one con which I said
to Theresa May which I apologize for
didn't say it - I said it about her and
and another one they found was a thing
where I said I'd love to program this
was when I was in the middle of
gamergate which I'd love to talk to you
about because that's that's I've got a
lot of revised feelings about gamergate
but during gamergate when when you know
gamers were some gamers were behaving
and very kind of you know anti-gay or
antenor misogynistic ways I said I
looked at program a gay pride march
through the middle of Karachi and Call
of Duty you know and they did an
impression in quotes of the of the
gamers going you know going and they
found this one and they printed it up as
an example of me using words you know so
so it's a what it what it is is apart
from being the censorious anti-liberal
and an undemocratic thing is is it it's
a political lever you know III don't
know if you Benjamin boys points this
out a lot and it's basically they're
using the language of you know moral
superiority or whatever you want to call
it - - to get ahead you know to get
political positions to win
student-student places you know and you
know it's it's political it's purely
political and if you master this
language then you know you can you can
get ahead it's so cynical it's so
cynical
you know imagine imagine two gay people
right and word [ __ ] into a search
engine and try to find some some some
example of Rome think you know there
it's twisted but anyway sorry I'm you
gotta you gotta stop me rambling I will
ramble no no rambling is great rambling
is what the podcast is all about but
also as well but you look at commish
in comedy and it would seem to me that
the quality of comedy that has been
commissioned has gone down and do you
think that when you look at you know
because you look back at father Ted
there was some real instances there
where the comedy was very much on the
knuckle do you think that that would be
allowed to be slipped past now or well
it's been a long time since I've kind of
swum in the in the in those waters I my
last my last show mother land is
slightly different I'm not involved with
mother land anymore but but Kent Arthur
was my attempt to write a family comedy
because they kind of thought I kind of
thought when you get them right they
they go really big you know it can be
really successful you know so I did my
best and I think I didn't I think we got
a couple of things wrong I think the
location was wrong a bit two people
didn't want to spend all their time in
one of those plastic cafes you know but
but so so I don't know about that kind
of near local edgy comedy anymore I
don't I'll give you a good example
something that I can't really see being
made now is price I can see brass are
getting anywhere because the you know I
don't think it's it's a much a.m. I
don't think it's so much that everyone's
becoming Morris and Sirius I think it's
that there's a couple of generations
that have grown up with the internet and
find any kind of test of their views
violent they think that it's a violent
act to question or or hold out their
views up to to you know ridicule or
whatever it happens to be they think
that's literally violence and and it's
very hard to get things done I would
imagine it's very hard to to
circumnavigate all that stuff you know
my sense also as well just for as an
outside observer is I don't know the
balls on the commissioners and the
producers seemed to have shrunk over the
decades because in the past I think they
would have been prepared to stand up for
things that they believe in any of
we knew it was going to attract
controversy whereas now it seems like
you know if you are anticipating there's
going to be a few complaints amplified
by social media then you'd rather not
take that risk do you think that there's
an element of truth in that as well
wants to be on the end of a something
like that but on the other hand people
really I mean this goes not just for
commissioners but for businesses and
universities and everyone people have to
realize how easy it is to set up a thing
where hundreds of people are writing to
you telling you that the person you've
employed is a monster or whatever it is
and and I'm and it's really getting
annoying the way the way these idiots
back down as soon as they're you know I
get there's certain people who regularly
there's certain people I see in my
Twitter feed their socks for other
people and we know who they are we know
you know there's only there's only one
of the things that we've been trying to
do throughout all this fight is trying
to get these LGBT organizations to call
out the bad actors in their midst
you know you get someone like Stephanie
Hayden who's a fraudster Amy Challinor
who was you know whose father was an
abuser a tortured a little girl and then
marrying a pedophile in America you know
it's like these are these are people who
should not be involved in safeguarding
should not be as Amy Challinor was
running an LGBT youth group for ages 14
plus or something these are these are
dangerous people
Jonathan Yaniv is another example and
they're dangerous people and they they
they need to be called out now someone
like Yaniv has hundreds of soccer coats
you know and he has a he has program
running that just automatically checks
for his name so that he can then report
them you know and this person got Megan
Murphy one of the you know an important
Canadian feminists kicked off Twitter
forever you know
now we people have got to realize that
they are being manipulated by sociopaths
you know there's other people that you
know the writers of pink news there
they're like demented you know like
there's one is written a few pieces on
me think what's her name think of
something and she's just eaten or by
rage you know and and it's um you know
we gotta stop listening to these people
one of the things the internet did and
again this made a real journey made a
real journey or last couple years but
one of these things into the internet I
used to be a bit of a internet utopian
to some degree I kind of thought I
remember when music was being destroyed
I thought oh this is great it means
it'll it'll make it it means any bands
will get bigger and be more access to -
and they'll be able to make their own
money they'll be able to skip the middle
the record companies the middleman and
don't make so much money but student
[ __ ] they're all [ __ ] starving
you know and and it was because
capitalism was was too robust you know
and all these people just stopped no no
I don't you know if we can't make money
then the musicians will starve that was
the fear and I used to think and another
thing that I thought was great was the
fact that Whitney with Facebook and
Twitter and all these things I thought
that we this kind of hive mind with
widget which is not actually that sounds
- - like I'm saying people would become
would walk in lockstep which has
terrible but I did think that the
connectivity that we all had would lead
to I thought it would lead to
breakthroughs in science I thought it
would lead I mean when I say it it
sounds it sounds completely reasonable
doesn't it I don't think you're wrong
actually Graham and I want to get into
the story of how you've kind of evolved
because you've got required journey but
I don't think you're wrong I think it
has had massive massive benefits oh but
but it's also had a lot of disadvantages
but since we've delved into the whole
story just to finish my thought was very
say that
what has happened that I think is very
very dangerous is that a bunch of
sociopaths I've injected themselves into
the the world brain yeah and we are now
repeating things that are insane you
know just insane because these
sociopaths are working the controls no I
know what you mean so let's let's dig
into that but let's start at the
beginning because I introduced you as
the the man behind some of the most
beloved shows in the history of
television I don't think that's
inaccurate so you've got a great career
you're going along nicely you're working
you know you respected loved your work
is loved and then suddenly you go from
that to being cautioned by the police
for dead naming and I wasn't cautioned
like caution sorry spoken to by the
police yeah that was Stephanie Hayden
yes who is very funny Stephanie Hayden
in court they said they pointed out that
she was convicted for free he was
convicted for fraud I'm not coming
Stephanie Hayden is she no way but he he
was convicted for fraud and he said oh
that was just for passing bad checks in
Wales yeah I've got the police they said
do you know Stephanie Hayden and I
thought they were calling because they
caught him now they called me to stop
stop there to leave him alone you know
and this was I had I had a blocked by
this stage so I hid basically what
Hayden was doing was he was getting a
police call and he said and he sued me
on the same weekend because how Hayden
works is he likes to he's done this to
it he did this to a transsexual friend
of mine in Norwich he he Sue's you he
calls police on the same weekend he
doesn't send a letter of intent or
whatever it's called the thing that says
if you take this down I'll go to you he
does it all to maximize distress than
dead he puts people on earth and that's
who the police call be that's what the
Guardian story is right so but what I
want to get into before we get into all
the nitty-gritty I mean yes sorry no I
get it because it's a very personal
one who's been in the middle of a media
storm myself I understand all of that
the little details piss you off and it's
it's all there but what I want to
understand this first and foremost what
made you decide to go from beloved
cultural figure to this guy on the
internet talking about women's rights
and being attacked by trans activists
what was it that you were like I can't
stomach this anymore I have to speak on
this I'm not sure that it was one single
thing it was after a while like once you
recognize this you realize that there is
a real lockdown on on information about
this you know and I was in my Twitter
bubble of liberal left-wing leaning
people and I would see things every so
often that that's like I remember one
that said you know what I was thinking
why have so many people Transnet
everyone everyone everyone's brother is
trans you know everyone you know and
then I saw a thing that said it says
because more accepted now more people
are coming and just as trans you know
and and I remember reading all this and
thinking okay you know but the more I
kind of thought about and the more crazy
stuff that started coming out I I
realized I was being gas lit you know
and then and then something happened it
was coming to the end of the Irish
repeal the eighth campaign which me and
my wife had my wife and I had had
participated in and I think to pretty
good effect I think we made a video that
was quite powerful and it did a lot of
good you know but but the people who
were running the the repeal thing in
Ireland included a bunch of people who
I'll give you an example of what they
did they ran I think that they had a
blocker up called repeal shield an
appeal shield was supposedly to block
Magda types but it also without telling
anyone they also put feminists in there
you know and so I'm not the same
time they got marriage equality passed
and they did that thing I don't know if
you saw the legal doctor with the
Denton's Denton's is this legal firm
this is amazing who advise trans
activists wanted to pass something that
said that kids didn't have to consult
their parents or didn't have to get
their parents permission if they began
transition right and he wants to get
that put into law and a law firm called
Denton's advised said wrote this
document where they said look to Ireland
Ireland did great work passing gender ID
on the back of more success or more
popular reforms like marriage equality
you know so that's what they did they
slipped it in and they and another thing
the tenten's document said is try and
avoid the media you know I mean as I've
said before what kind of what kind of
civil rights group avoids the media you
know so so all this stuff was piling up
and then I had cancer and I was I was in
I I was on morphine this was I always
have to do that because I think the
morphine made me a lot braver than I
should have been and oh my god and I saw
a thing that said you know now we've
dealt with repeal there's an Irish
person now we've dealt with appeal I
want to tell the grain in hand as a turf
and they included a bunch of things I'd
like tanned so on you know the usual
things that are just no one could
objective unless you're insane you know
like trans people deserve respect and
help but women deserve their rights too
that's it you know so I saw that I was
being cancelled and I kind of got a bit
Signet down and I kind of thought well
what what am I saying that's wrong and I
and I examined it and it wasn't anything
I wasn't saying anything wrong you know
and I still stand by I've never really
said anything like this stuff you know I
can back up all my opinions you know but
Graham wasn't there a part of you know I
mean you clearly feel strongly about
this
and that's fine but wasn't there a
self-preservation gene that was I hang
on mate if you tweet this you're gonna
get into some serious problem speakers
we've all written a tweet and then
looked at in thought not headed to leak
that you know out that well no because I
wasn't saying anything wrong I was
saying I was and also I was standing up
for reality I mean like I saw did you
see the thing that tweeted yesterday the
guy you've got thanked by the board of
educators didn't oh yeah okay here it is
this is just extraordinary I'll send it
to you and you know I've sent this to
various people who I hate like you know
Josie long and I know Ann Jones and so
on and and they never answer because
there's no answer to it you know and
it's it's this guy like so anyway that's
a man right that is a man okay
people he's put me saying that this is a
man over the shock of the map please
yeah that's the map and if we are to
make comedy there has to be a base of
reality there has to be and it and any
form of writing you have to have a base
of reality so if something like this is
happening you have two choices you can
you can adopt you can adapt to the new
reality or you can fight against it and
I just chose to fight against it because
comedy is impossible if that's a woman
impossible you know and you talk about
adapting to reality one of the things I
wanted to raise with you is the count
thank Euler case okay because you've
gone through quite an evolution on many
issues that being a good example where
you know we've had thank a lot on the
show and we've talked to him about his
case and I think at the time you felt
that his joke was you know he was a way
of supporting the Nazis or he wasn't
maybe a Nazi or maybe he's far right and
I think you even helped or kind of
organized the taking down of his
fund me page and stuff like that and
you've since then you know to change
your position to diametrically opposite
and I think you apologized to Marcus so
talk to us about that and what happened
there because these your free speech in
relation to all of these things is kind
of the crucial issue because if you
can't talk about what the truth is then
it becomes very difficult isn't it yeah
but I have to say that my interest in
this doesn't come from a free speech
angle I think it's even more fundamental
in a weird way it's really about being
able to say what reality is I think
we're not able to say where reality is
then we will go mad right but that's
what's free speech is poised mine is my
point grab me if you don't have free
speech and then you can't say what
reality is
sure but but but I my I thought the
reality of Cain killer was that he was a
he you know I saw that he had videos on
storm front I saw that he was he was
taking pictures with Tommy Robinson you
know and I I did that thing that I
assembled a an identikit of him that
possibly wasn't true all all that
possibly wasn't the whole truth you know
but I do think you know things like
things that I can the Pakistan flag and
all that stuff they they really I do
find all that stuff grim because because
it was to me it was kind of cheering on
one of the worst things that's happened
to humanity which is Trump's win you
know I I wonder if we get four more
years will the world survive it you know
so you know I also at that point I saw
the rise of the fire right and I was
really worried about I'm really scared
they were getting a hold and I saw this
and you know I combined that with there
was a thing I think Vox Dei Rose or
someone like that about how to hide your
real anti-semitic or whatever it has to
be intentions with in comedy because
comedy is easier to absorb and stuff
like that but with with Derrick EULA I
just think I mean I know now that he's
like he's just
someone who just I don't know like
spoken those buttons I guess you know
but Sam yeah but you know I mean I mean
the thing about the the getting the
phoneme brought down was I read I
remembered late after I apologized that
he did say it was for an appeal
that never happened that I do remember
that around that time they were a lot of
right-wing people were monetizing these
these these stances and I kind of put
him under that umbrella
you know the appeal did happen just to
be just to be that and the appeal did
happen yeah I'm not trying to get you to
apologize again because you already did
what I want to find out is one of the
things I found very interesting when
when the article came out and you
retweeted it yourself and said you
partly agree with it was that you said
you were now skeptical about some of the
people who were cheering you on oh yeah
as you were criticizing thank Allah talk
to us about that well ah
when gamergate starting gamergate was
something that I felt proud of right up
until recently you know because I I I
saw it as a just a misogynistic a
campaign in fact between tear up Graham
because there'll be people listening and
water
you know what gamergate is can you just
give a brief description of what it is
and then your attitudes to it yeah and
and my description I'll try and make my
description what I thought it was what I
now realize it was I was what I thought
gamergate was in its entirety again like
but thank you that was a hate campaign
aimed at women in the gaming industry
that was you know they were I was
employing things like swatting you know
there were women gamers who were being
the [ __ ] SWAT teams were coming to
their house killing a woman I think her
dog was killed because that's the first
thing they do when a SWAT team comes out
to your house you know so so again
because it was women being targeted my
my anger reflex has gone up because
that's the thing I really can't bear and
and and I just jumped into it and and
and that's what I thought it was but
what it really was was a confluence of
millions of different things happening
at the same time there were a lot of and
I now realize there were a lot of young
men who were much closer to the truth of
what was happening in colleges and stuff
that I was who realized that there was
this sense aureus liberal canceling kind
of culture that was really dangerous you
know and they were all mixed up with
with with the real right-wingers and
people like you novelists who who it
seemed to me was very cynically cashing
in and trying to try to recruit young
men into the right in fact I think he
actually said that that's what he was
doing and so you know at the time I was
just very hard line I was like you know
people would say what is gamergate i was
confused by gamergate and i would say
it's a misogynistic a campaign and
that's all it is you know I had a very
hard line you know view it but I now
realize that a lot of the people on my
side I was one one person called super
gamer girl you know and I saw a picture
of Bob Lowe with a huge beard and these
are the people who who were who were
doing all this I thought I was defending
women some of the time and so what a
time I wasn't even I was defending
blokes you know and so so it was it's so
I now see that what it really is is a
kind of a tribalistic war especially in
America between between two groups is a
kind of anarchic kind of Bernie bro
types I guess he'd say and then on the
other side you have these a combination
of Magha types but also you know people
who are just you just like pushing the
buttons on the other side you know I
think it's all bad because in India
you know you can't treat everything like
a joke I remember when Trump won a bunch
of right-wingers said we did it we
elected a meme you know and and and it
might be fun and you might fit and I'm
sure gives a huge feeling of power but
you know it's it's now killing their
friends and family you know so so I mean
with you know the response to
coronavirus so so my my by after with by
being canceled getting into this fight I
realized that there were a lot more
currents that I was aware of and I to be
honest with you I'm very proud of the
I'm very proud of what I've done in the
women's rights thing recently but I I
think I may have made a few mistakes in
the gamergate time yeah well I think
that's not a nun you know some people
will look at that and go oh she was a
hypocrite which I think one of the
article said it by you actually think
someone who's able to change their mind
over time I think that's something that
every person should be proud of is
growing as a human being and learning
and changing your mind as you realize
more I think that's pretty pretty it's a
healthy thing to do
yeah absolutely I mean you know one
thing that I've realized recently is
something we should all guard against is
certainty you know and and I like being
on this side of this fight because so
many people are telling us we're wrong
me and the feminists I support that you
spend you most your time going am I
wrong
I'm thinking about it and kind of you
know then and there you know it's
something it's something that one should
do and I think my experience of
gamergate will will mean and going don't
you think part of the problem with the
Internet is that we have these
discussions or debates whether it's you
know the trans debate which is
incredibly nuanced there's a lot you
know there's a lot of depth to this and
we're trying to do it over Twitter on I
can't remember how many characters
Twitter has but you simply can't do it
over that type of platform and also as
well it's really in order to have these
types of to conversations debate they
were
need to be done face-to-face aren't they
wouldn't say yeah but it's not happening
because they like as you know one of the
one of stone walls cast iron rules was
no debate
you know they dis Denton's document
which which perhaps you could put in the
link to your I'll send you they'll send
you put put in the link in the video you
know saying to avoid media scrutiny is
is just extraordinary and I will notice
when have you ever seen a debate between
two opposing sides are so rare they're
so rare and it's because what happens
and it's another pretty way of silencing
women in this because they're using the
the news kind of ecosystems against it
against itself because the news won't
get someone on unless there's an
opposing view so if they get someone
like Kathleen stock to talk about
something then the other side can go no
she's that she's a she's a tariff or not
I'm not appearing with her and then the
piece just doesn't happen you know so so
yeah I agree
Twitter's a terrible place for it to
happen but you know I thought I'd use it
in a different way I thought I would
just keep hammering hammering hammering
hammering the points home over and over
again until people couldn't restate the
points and even that doesn't work
because yesterday I got message from two
bearded bluetick idiots who are like I'd
love to know what happened to Graeme
Innes what the [ __ ]
you know like timeline is right there
you know and none of the things I'm
posting there's a good answer to so they
just ignore it it's the strangest thing
but yeah Twitter makes it possible to do
that for some reason I think gas
lighting is the time you used and I
think when it comes to you know look
you've seen int over the posi Parker for
example where you know we pushed back on
her pretty hard about some of the things
because that's our job and we get to try
to get to the bottom of some of these
conversations but you know this
biological reality and we are now in a
position that you find yourself in that
when you express clearly what is in my
view and this is why I don't think they
do much polling on this because they
know what would happen if they didn't
know right that's the view
ninety-five percent of the country if
you say to people if you're born a man
you know can you change your sex most
people would say no right yes now that's
not because they hate trans people it's
just because it's a fundamental
biological reality and we are now in the
position where you know if you if you if
you express strongly your view that that
is the case you're automatically
considered transphobic yeah no I mean
that's it
and the bar is so low like we've seen
what happened to JK Rowling when she
when she tweeted a completely
compassionate and reasonable thing you
know and then they can't there's also so
many trans people who agree with us more
and more every day you know who are just
who are just in despair at the damage
that's being done because of these
lunatics you know and and there does
have to be a little videos have to be
gatekeeping in this sense because there
are certainly different types of people
who are drawn to this you know there are
like like the the the the the ideology
is so incoherent that it means that I
mean you know the best example of how
incoherent the the ideology is is a
Karen white the trans woman I don't even
think it's a transform no take the piss
but Karen white got into a women's
prison and and sexually assaulted four
women in a women's prison in the UK
where segregation is still the law of
the land
that's how bamboozled said the prison
service whereby stonewalls advice and
that that kind of advice is now seen
through so many different kind of
institutions and so on any and it
doesn't it doesn't hold up it doesn't
hold up to anything so you're you're
constantly second-guessing yourself and
I remember someone wrote a brilliant
thing where they said I've written I've
written something hopefully it isn't
transphobic and it's like it's like
they've just kind of painted themselves
into the stupidest corner you know and I
mean beyond me
I wish there were some like like it
makes no difference
but I tagged in this morning I sent that
photograph of that bloke to Jon Ronson
in them and Frankie Boyle and a few
other people who who do the transmitter
women thing let's say you know is this a
woman or whatever you know and they
think Billy Bragg immediately got me you
know and it's like it's just hilarious
they can't they can't answer the
questions that they've set up for
themselves you know what I mean it's so
strange so so anyway you know the one
thing I wanted to talk about and
actually with the three of us because
it's unresolved for me is you know
Frances and I'd remember Frances when we
first even started getting people on to
talk about this we were like well you
know it's it's a minority she wasn't
it's like something that you know
effects like no point whatever percent
of the population is it really worth
talking is it really that interesting
but I was always standing with women
Graham just but it's it's become a major
issue for I think for the reason that
you say because yes of course the
women's rights issue is a big one but it
speaks to a much more fundamental thing
which is do we live in a society where
you are able to speak the truth and what
this is revealing is their areas of life
on where you are not able to speak the
truth because if you do you know at best
people will have the experience of you
eat that you've had right sure yeah but
the shame is that all you need is help -
all we need to happen is for more people
to raise their voice you know the
biggest the biggest problem is people
frightened to say to say it people who
are you know I mean a lot of women on
Twitter have to be anonymous who are
talking about this because because if
they use their big they're scared of
using their real accounts because they
might get bad you know but I remember
when Twitter brought in their
misgendering rules one tweet said
Twitter have changed her terms and
conditions so misgendering is not a
happy hunting everyone you know so this
is men silencing women you know
so so yeah it's tight personally approve
of but it's the Russian way mate it's
the Russian way well it's kind of them
but what I just there's two things I
don't understand first things I don't
know somewhere more people aren't
speaking up because once you speak up
you create a you create an atmosphere
that makes makes it okay for other
people to speak up and suddenly you're
not alone sort of it like me for
instance I'm completely isolated amongst
my celebrity friends at home what are
two people who are speaking up for me
who I'll always be grateful to but for
the most part they not only don't speak
up for you they actually come out
against you like you know I showed the
photograph of some 50 year old chancer
on a on a on a college basketball team
with some girls you know and Jon Ronson
criticized me for sharing the photograph
not for this pervert on this team you
know taking advantage again of these
incoherent rules so I just find it's
just extraordinary people won't just not
say anything but they'll go the extra
mile and I'll actually throw women under
the boss you know I mean Ronson I'm like
he it blows my mind you know the king of
nuance I mean and he believes that he
believes it transparent you know it's
just he does not see any of the problems
he doesn't see today and he doesn't
think women's sports are important
enough to be bothered about he doesn't
he doesn't think that you know the
safeguarding problems that arise you
know yeah I don't know if you or whether
you should you follow my feet at all but
you know one of the things I share that
blows me away is a sign in a toilet that
says if you see anyone in here that
looks out of place don't question them
they know better than you do you know
you young girl and a man approaches you
in the [ __ ] toilet then a poster like
that is making that young girl less safe
it's taking even more power away from
that younger
you know so the fact that someone like
Frankie Boyle and sorry a little name
you know hated so much but Frankie boy
the Jon Ronson Josey dawn and all these
people the fact that they will fight
fight for that man and not for that
young girl it blows my mind
every day you know to be honest with you
sometimes I read your tweets and I'm
like wow that is you know very much like
you said yourself like a blunt
instrument do you sometimes think that
actually if you approach this subject
with a little bit more nuance in your
tweets a little bit gentle maybe a
little bit more of a conciliators
conciliatory tone that the blowback
wouldn't be as harsh on you well no
because because as you know they don't
accept anything like JK Rowling got
cancelled because of one tweet yeah
so if that's the if that's how it's
gonna be then you might as well told it
you know tell the truth and the whole
truth you know and also the trans women
who support me in this not many do a
couple of trans men who support me and a
lot of D transitioners who are very nice
as well
but but but the trans women who support
me in this people like Debbie hatin and
Christina Harrison I mean Christina
Harrison said a brilliant thing in her
speech she said she talked about Eddie
Izzard said that Eddie Izzard is now
saying you know trans status you know
and and she said that she used to admire
Eddie Izzard when he used to say that he
was a transvestite that he or that he
was a crossdresser or whatever you want
to call it but now that he's saying this
you know he said something like but he's
not a woman and those are mine you know
and that's the trans women I'm friends
with brave you know they kind of face
their dysphoria they face their
condition with with real wood you know
from a reality based mindset and and
they're much happier than all these
miserable people who are who spend their
time haunting feminists down and you
know you know it's it's
it's just it's we're encouraging a form
of mental illness do you think do you
think we're making some progress on a
diagram I mean we've just had the review
of the gender recognition act in the UK
which now says that you have to be 18
before you before you're able to
transition do you think we're starting
to see that reality is making a comeback
I do a little bit yeah yeah I think that
you know it's it's as a lifelong lefty
although I've lost my tribalism
completely it's going will do that to
you it's galling that the Conservatives
in it but but you know I don't care who
stands up for women as honest or those
you know and they've been great and
their labour has been an absolute joke I
mean here's here's how fundamentally
this issue destroys women's rights Jo
Swinson I think lost because of it if
you can't answer who what a woman is on
TV
then how can anyone vote for you you
know and the labor leaders all the fee
all the women labor leaders make
absolute pricks of themselves on on TV
you know and Lisa Natalie said that
pedophiles should be housed with them
with mail app with female prisoners Don
Butler with her with her babies are born
without a sex I don't agree with walk
around the yard Lee said about that I
think she meant it I think she doubled
down on it and you know I'm calling
college most outrageously of all and I
really wish they'd sue but they keep
having their funding stopped so it's
hard for them to sue anyone but LGB
alliance and women's place UK i know
these [ __ ] women you know being two
people in Lynda Lynda Pelops you know
who started their Black History Month I
think in the UK
Helen Steele who sued McDonald's on her
own and one you know these are absolute
stars of left-wing activism and they're
being you know Helen Steele had a point
of beer thrown in her face
when she turned up to defender a student
who was being bullied for being gender
critical you know the lack of respect
for left-wing heroes is extraordinary
you know again sometimes I get waylaid
and I'm not sure where it began that
said we began with me asking whether you
think we're making progress so I think
the the gender recognition act situation
certainly I think you'd consider
progress is gonna be huge
when caramel wins her case or even if
she loses and people see this per kid
who whose voice is now a man's voice and
whose facial structure has been changed
forever who says she shouldn't have been
told she shouldn't been that do these
things to herself when she was 16 when
more people see this they'll they'll
wake up I think and gram so you think
that we're we're moving essentially in
the right direction now do you think
that we've copied we might see it a
gentler kinder I can already tell what
your answer is gonna be but anyway but I
can see more people so it seems now also
I have a feeling we'll come at thinking
wondering whether that five-day week is
actually a good idea whether you know we
should have three days to hang out with
our kids rather run to and do you know
what I mean I think things I think at
home I don't know I think it could be
good it could be good long-term my big
worry is I need to get the [ __ ]
theatres open to so and so I can just
put on the Ted musical you know that's
that's the that's the thing I really
need to happen don't we old David I'm so
David sure whether queen of climate
sorry I've been living on what happened
there's we've just had an iris guest on
the show and you just think you're all
the same
that is but it's fine because you're
white and a man therefore I can do that
stop being stop being white fragile or
white showing white fragility to me but
the one thing I wanted to talk to you
about as well and it's because we touch
on cancellation and you've been very
joking about it but what did what was
cancellation what happened to you and
what would the implications of it well
funnily enough I I I kind of plan for it
you know all this in a weird way I did I
did say to myself I'm gonna do this for
a while I had some money from my cancer
treatment so I thought I would saw it so
I and you know and people were being
nice to me because I had cancer so I
thought well I'll use this time to not
work and I'll just throw myself into
this and I'll be protected for a while
by the the cancer money and then I got
the Ted musical you know so hopefully
the 10:00 news will the phone sir and
and you know because I thought if they
attacked the Ted musical it will just
kind of bring more attention to it and
they'll see why the public will see how
insane this stuff is and but you know
then the Ted musical took a lot longer
than I thought and and and and the
things I did try and get going nearly
all of them you know when North had one
phone call from a guy who who you know
he picked up from full of enthusiasm
offers me this great job and I said okay
yeah great that's brilliant you know put
down the phone maybe five minutes later
cause I'm sorry it's been taken by
someone else I was you know and I
thought about it for a while and I mean
I realize I knew exactly what happened
this guy went out today to the office
and he said guess what everybody I got
rain liniment to do it you know and the
intern put up their hand and so he's a
bigot that's it you know cause you don't
want to get the you don't to get the
younger members of staff how angry you
know so so yeah so that's a you have to
work you lost friends yeah
you've had that police call you and I
feel good about the friends I swapped
out my
Fairweather friends for feminists and
you know people who really believe in
things may I know exactly what you mean
that is one of the great things about
doing this show for us is we've swapped
all the people that we thought were our
friends yeah there were no friends for
people that actually understand what
we're talking about and why we're doing
it and you know and they might not agree
with us on every issue of politics but
they they understand the importance of
truths and reality of [ __ ] and
conformity he's lying we're completely
on our own Graham this is something
Sarah he was ashamed to say because he
used to hate terms like triggered and
and all that sort of stuff because they
thought it was kind of and even even now
I still know a huge fan of things like
titania without because I find all that
stuff what I now realize is that is that
it was it was actually true these you
know all this stuff was true and and I
do find my thing is you can't it's hard
to make full of it when the true stuff
is so mad you know and and I realized
but I really not so I thought that
people were exaggerating I thought
people were exaggerating about the state
of you know transyl culture and all that
sort of stuff and I think a lot of
people think that you know yeah but of
course it's it's it's so true people get
people get fired for the most insane
things like the like Helen what who was
a dural guy leader you know who objected
to not only boys suddenly being able to
sleep in the same tent as girls but but
Girl Guide leaders being able to be men
and parents don't have to be notified
and even on even on a smaller level I
mean as the sakta guy who shared the
billy connolly routine about religion on
his facebook yeah and the routine was a
from a DVD that they sell in as that so
so that's where but you know on titania
and you know triggered and all this kind
of stuff I mean I think Android oil into
town is actually a very good it's a
mirror you know and that that is the
function of comedy sometimes
particularly satire not so much comedy
but satays to hold up a mirror to
society and say look this is what it
looks like you know and that's not
comfortable and people don't like it
just like they don't like you making
things black and white in the way that
some things in life are you're saying is
this a man or is this a woman people
don't like that because it forces them
to confront their own duplicity and
their own weakness and their own fear
that's why people don't like it that's
why I think some people don't like to
tonyia and the same with us I mean yes
we call the show trigonometry but it's
actually more of a trigger warning than
anything we're saying
if you are uncomfortable with
controversial discussions don't watch
you know what we're not we're not 12
year olds right now oh sorry good you
know like no I get that now again you
know there's I can talk about myself as
a kind of a lab rat you know and we must
talk someday about about how I thought
about all these things you know because
I I kind of see no I didn't know fruit
for me it's like do you remember when
what do you remember sorry but the head
of the Emily fire head of mi5 was a
Russian agent who was that again what
was his name you're very very close in
two races hi mate mate mate be kind
you're talking about his uncle come on I
forget one of the Cambridge spies right
leaves the head of he was the head of
mi5 for four for four years didn't old
damage said sent sent houses of people
to or you know hundreds of agents to be
to be tortured to death
you know knowingly you know by putting
them on missions and then telling the
Russians
they were coming and stuff like this and
then after that there was a there was a
few years where mi5 simply didn't know
who to trust and they were totally
paranoid and kind of fighting amongst
themselves blah blah blah now I know
that's this is a very roundabout way of
getting here but but but you read a John
the Kerry novel and so complicated so
hard to take in it's all that kind of
spirit in that time and but it says
nothing compared to the Internet the
Internet is a Hall of Mirrors you know
and we have no idea who we're talking to
we have no idea if we're doing the right
thing at any one moment it's it's I I
think that as a species we weren't ready
for it and we're still not ready and
we're still adjusting you know I think
there have to be lots of conversations
about the effect of porn on kids you
know whether porn is making young girls
feel feel want to escape their sexuality
whether it's making your [ __ ] that was
what it's doing to young boys but when
you see a 20 year old kid in pigtails
you know it's like no no no it was
really gone around 20 year old male with
pigtails and simpering at the camera and
you know with a patreon link in their in
their in their name it's it's there's
got to be a conversation about why do
you hate progress so much Graham listen
mate speaking of conversations we'd love
to have you back on the show when we can
do it in studio and we can continue
because we've run out of time yeah it's
an interesting subject all this is now
it is no we'd love to come we'd love to
have you back when we can sit down and
talk face-to-face I think that would be
great but thank you very much for coming
on and we just got one more question for
you mate
and the question always is Graham what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that we really should be oh
god okay oh I know right if if people
want to follow you your Twitter remind
everybody what your Twitter is if they
want to check out your work and activism
I suppose it would be the right way
scribing it is Gloria HP Leonard Gleaner
we'll make sure to put it in the video
thanks for coming on and we'll see all
of you who've been watching very soon
and we'll see gram very soon for another
interview when we can do it face to face
definitely okay solutely I might be
honest I can't wait for the father Ted
musical it's gonna be blinding and the
souls are amazing so far I think we
really nailed it you know very we did
lose one job the other day where Google
says then someone comes dude was stupid
he says I'll never be Albert Epstein
that's for sure all right thanks very
much thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word